[Musica]
se volete potete chiudere gli occhi
che fai tu luna in ciel
[Musica]
dimmi che fai silenziosa luna
sorci da sera e vai contemplando i
deserti i tifosi
ancor non sei tu guarda
ancora non credi di essere
ancor 6 vaga di mira queste mano
somiglia la tua vita ramella del pastore
9 la grecia oltre per campo e vede
greggi frontale ed erbe
poi stacco si riposa in sulla sera altro
mai bene
i libri
a che fare al posto la sua vita
nostra vita
dimmi dove tenne questo pagare un mio
breve il tuo corso
[Musica]
vi voglio confessare una cosa perché
vedete il mio talk non doveva iniziare
così sapete
dietro a questi discorsi c'è un sacco di
preparazione e io saro pronto era fatto
funzionava almeno mi hanno detto così a
una domanda da spararvi subito in faccia
dritto sapete tecniche di retorica
queste cose così poi per non so quale
caso ho studiato proprio in questo
periodo a scuola leopardi
ho conosciuto così giacomino e proprio
leggendo queste questi versi magnifici
che adesso abbiamo ascoltato insieme io
ho riletto nelle sue parole la mia
stessa domanda com'è possibile
leopardi un genio assoluto io persona
qualsiasi
la stessa domanda come è possibile e mi
sono dato una risposta perché vedete ho
detto noi siamo sempre stati noi
l'uomo è sempre stato uomo e io davide
persona qualsiasi e leopardi e tu che
sta in prima fila e lui e l'operaio che
ha costruito questo posto condividendo
la nostra umanità ci siamo fatti le
stesse domande
per questo fatto di essere uomini di
stare tutti qua a vivere questa vita ci
siamo domandati prima o poi dove stiamo
andando
è questa la domanda con cui volevo
partire dove stiamo andando
ove tende questo pagarmi a breve e per
spiegarvela vi racconto la sua storia
perché ha una storia dunque ero in
classe
vedete sono uno studente o 18 anni sto
all'ultimo anno del liceo e mentre ero
in classe e pensavo proprio a questo a
ripetersi delle mie giornate in modo
paul altro perché vedete io riesco a
ricordarmi perfettamente quello che ho
pensato in quel momento da quello che
adesso andrò a raccontare però non
riesco a ricordare quale lezione fosse
il perché ve lo dico subito perché io
assisto a una lezione 5 6 volte al
giorno tutti i giorni della settimana
tranne che uno da otto anni
senza contare le elementari quindi la
ripetitività nelle mie giornate
io pensavo proprio a questo mentre stavo
la il luogo che vedo tutti i giorni
mentre ormai mi astra evo e la voce del
professore che non faceva che da
sottofondo ad andare frenetico dei miei
pensieri mi è sorto proprio questo
dubbio ma dove stiamo andando cioè cosa
sto facendo io in questo momento che
cos'è che mi spinge ogni giorno ad
alzarmi e fare la stessa cosa a venire
qua qual è il senso ce lo siamo
domandati in tanti perché alla fine
questa domanda se astra chiamo giorno
dopo giorno la vita
qual è il senso della nostra vita dove
tende alla nostra vita a cosa ci porta
cosa sto facendo io in questo momento
vedete quando nazione diventa
abitudinaria rischiamo certe volte di
dimenticarci perché la facciamo
qual è il senso di questa azione mi
viene un esempio con gli insegnanti
perché siamo in questo ambito ci sono
degli insegnanti mi potete alzare la
mano ok perfetto
beh anno dopo anno le elezioni non vi
offendete sono quasi sempre le stesse ma
non perché adesso le stesse perché gli
argomenti da da insegnare sono quelli e
io penso che sia capitato anche a voi
mentre facevate una lezione che magari
avevate ripetuto solo qualche ora prima
un'altra classe o anche sei mesi prima
vi siate un attimo distratti fermati
anche soltanto col pensiero mentre
andavate vi siete chiesti che sto
facendo ha un senso questa cosa ma
vedete vale per tutto
quando una cosa diventa automatica per
esempio quando ci avete fatto caso
quando ripetiamo una parola tante volte
consecutivamente una dopo l'altra
che poi non riusciamo più a ricordarci
che cosa significa non associamo quella
parola quel suono al suo significato
io credo che sia successo a tutti beh è
di questo che sto parlando e vedete
quello che ho pensato io in quel momento
a scuola e che noi ci tiriamo indietro e
vediamo la nostra strada già tracciata
il percorso che noi abbiamo messo fasi
faticosamente in piedi
passo dopo passo come se fosse stato
disegnato da qualcun altro qualcuno
che ci ha detto e continua a dirci ogni
giorno cosa dobbiamo fare
alzati la mattina vai a scuola o lavoro
che sia abitudini poi trovi un posto
nella società di andare all'università
trovati un masso una specializzazione fa
gli straordinari porta a casa al lavoro
matrimonio figli abitudine abitudine
abitudini ancora abitudini però ho
pensato un'altra cosa
se io vi dicessi a ora che questo non è
vero che questo ragionamento è fallace è
falso è sbagliato o meglio in realtà è
vero è vero
finché rimaniamo chini sulle nostre
scrivanie e non portiamo il nostro
sguardo più avanti del nostro naso è
vero finché rimarremo concentrati su
quella piccola minuscola macchiolina che
sporca la nostra scarpa ma se noi
alziamo lo sguardo dai nostri piccoli
affanni dai nostri piccoli affari
quotidiani e ci rendiamo conto di quello
che abbiamo intorno di essere inserito
in un contesto molto più grande vedete
anche quella strada di cui parlavo prima
ci sembrerà diversa se noi davvero
riusciremo a vederci come soltanto un
piccolo tassello all'interno di una
visione molto più grande
all'interno di un cantato come i puzzle
un pezzettino piccolissimo cioè inserito
all'interno di un puzzle però quasi
infinito quel pezzettino da solo non ha
senso anche il pazzo però tutto il resto
senza quel pezzettino non ha senso
allora noi dobbiamo fare dobbiamo
allargare la visione è questo punto
allargare la visione come quelle riprese
aeree non so se ci avete presenti
riprese aeree fatte da droni che partono
però da un particolare stretto da un
primo piano magari e poi vanno
allargandosi salgono salgono inglobano
prima una strada poi una città intera
poi escono il paese il continente e alla
fine escono dal mondo bellissime e tu
vedi il nostro mondo
da un altro punto di vista noi dobbiamo
fare così
cambiamo prospettiva e cambieremo
approccio vedete quello che intendo cosa
sono i nostri piccoli ma lì i nostri
piccoli affari quotidiani in confronto
con la grandezza totalizzante del mondo
possiamo davvero noi confrontarci che so
io con le ingiustizie che avvengono in
siria in palestina si parla tanto di
migranti si parla tanto di migranti
gente che lascia il proprio habitat
naturale la propria casa sapendo di
essere di andare incontro alla morte
praticamente perché parliamoci chiaro la
speranza è poca
però noi continuiamo a essere
concentrati sui nostri piccoli affari
nostri piccoli affanni vedete hegel
so che a molti non piace che diceva una
cosa ciò che è reale è razionale cioè
tutto quello che c'è c'è perché deve
esserci e quindi la realtà è perfetta
così come ho capito però esiste male è
vero ma anche quello fa parte della
visione anche quello fa parte del tutto
non ha senso
il tutto senza particolari non ha senso
il particolare sempre senza il tutto
citazione ultimo lo giuro
ciò bigliettino come a scuola saluto del
prof
e tiziano bersani ci vuole un senso di
sé che non sia quello vicino della
carriera e dei soldi che sia il senso
che sei parte di questa cosa
meravigliosa che è tutta qui attorno a
noi il nostro orizzonte del mondo
ecco un altro in cui io ritrovo dei
pensieri miei il nostro orizzonte al
mondo ecco cosa dice tiziano terzani e
allora se il nostro orizzonte è il mondo
torniamo a quella storia alla quel
ragazzo che sta in classe la scuola la
scuola diventa uno strumento perché se
noi capiamo il nostro orizzonte non è la
scuola ma allarghiamo allarghiamo
l'orizzonte è il mondo allora la scuola
ci servirà assolutamente come strumento
e lo dobbiamo sfruttare perché pensateci
se non ci fosse la scuola come
impareremmo che ne so la filosofia la
fisica materie difficili beh compreremo
un libro che ne parla
e cercheremo una persona più esperta di
noi che ne sa qualcosa ecco il
professore
e allora ragazzi adesso vi dirò una cosa
che sembra stupida però a pendere dalle
labbra di ogni vostro singolo professore
pendere dalle labbra di ogni vostro
singolo professore ha anche se di tutto
quello che dirà a voi servirà o vi
interesserà una sola parola ma quella
parola non perdetela perché non ricavi
da più è un'occasione unica mai
abbastanza vi voglio raccontare l'ultima
storia ci fu una rivoluzione di fatto
ci fu una rivoluzione di fatto che fu
guardata da tutti ma non dal punto di
vista che voglio sottolineare io ne
parla nanni un sociologo nel 1961 per la
prima volta l'uomo andò nello spazio e
vide il suo habitat naturale da un'altra
prospettiva
yuri gagarin si fece questo volo
spaziale bellissimo e vide la terra dove
ha sempre abitato da fuori dallo spazio
e cosa gli sembrò una piccola
insignificante arancia un arancia blu
ora il problema è che spesso noi non
riusciamo che a vedere quello spicchio
quella parte di spicchio su cui noi ci
troviamo in quel momento senza renderci
conto che ci stanno tutti gli altri e
allora ragazzi
guardatevi attorno rendetevi conto di
tutti gli spicchi che abbiamo e poi
create portate del vostro
a questo punto possiamo creare si
condividiamo idee
facciamoci taccuini portiamo innovazione
portiamo quello che abbiamo in testa noi
però sempre ricordandoci questa grande
visione e allora ci siamo conosciuti con
una domanda esistenziale dove stiamo
andando con il senso della vita mi vuoi
lasciare con una domanda di cucina
preferirete lo spicchio all arancia
intera
grazie
[Applauso]